قبيله ان عقاد قمه ال 20 كانت للرئيسين
الامريكيين والصيني جوله من المفاوضات
المهمه جدا ليس على مستوى القمه فقط وانما
لاهمتها ابعاد اقتصاديه وسياسيه وربما
عسكريه على مستوى العالم الرئيسان عقد
اجتماعا مطولا استمر على مدى ثلاث ساعات
متواصله شدد خلاله الزعيمان على الحاجه
الى اداره الخلافات وتجنب النساء
اكشن 2
والولايات المتحده تمر الان بحاله سيئه
ولا تصب في مصلحه البلدين والشعبين مشيرا
الى ضروره ايجاد الطريق الصحيح لهذه
العلاقات وتصحيح المسار
الصين والولايات المتحده مره عبر 50 سنه
حفله بالاحداث التاريخ هو افضل كتاب لذلك
علينا ان نستفيد منه العلاقات بين الصين
والولايات المتحده حاليا تمر بحاله تدفعنا
للاهتمام بها ولا تصب في مصلحه بلدين
وشعبين وليست ما يتوقعه من المجتمع الدولي
لاننا قائدين لاكبر دولتين في العالم
علينا ان الصيغه الطريقه المناسبه
للعلاقات لايجاد الاتجاه الصحيح للعلاقات
الثنائيه مستقبلا وتطوير هذه العلاقات